اكد الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان حق
بلاده في تحديد مناطق تحركها خارج الحدود
من اجل حمايه امنها وانه ليس بامكاني احد
منعها من استخدام هذا الحق وقد اكدت وزاره
الدفاع التركيه مواصلاتها قصف مواقع من
تسميهم الارهابيين في شمال العراق وسوريا
كما عقد وزير الدفاع اجتماعات مع قاده
الجيش كان اخر وافي مدينه هاكاري على
الحدود مع العراق
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كان ذاك خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاش ثلاثه مسارات ما هي
الرسائل التي يبعثوها اردوغان بتاكيده عدم
قدره احد على ايقاف عمليه بلاده العسكريه
شماليه العراقي وسوريا وتوالي لقاءات وزير
الدفاع مع قاده عملياته
وما هي امكانيه اتساع النطاق العمليات
العسكريه التركيه في شمالي سوريا والعراق
بحيث تشمل هجوما عسكريا بريا كما توعدت
انقره
وما فرص واحتواء التصعيد العسكريه على
حدود تركيا مع العراق وسوريا وايجاد حل
متفاوض عليه يرضي جميع الاطراف
[موسيقى]
فيما قرا فيه البعض ردا على الانتقادات
التي وجهتها قيوان اقليميه ودوليا للعمليه
العسكريه الشماليه سوريا والعراق اكيد
الرئيس تركيا
من اجل حمايه امنها وانه ليس بامكاني احد
منعو انقر من استخدام هذا الحق واضاف
اردوغوتي بلاده استطاعت تحديدا نحوي 4080
اما وصفهم بالارهابيين في العمليه
العسكريه الجاريه في العراق وسوريا
تصريحات اردوغان سبقها تاكيد وزاره الدفاع
التركيه مواصله قصفها مواقع من سمتهم
الارهابيين شماليه سوريا والعراق
ونشرت الوزاره في حسابي على موقع تويتر
مشاهد القصف المدعي الذي استهدفات تلك
المواقع
العمليه التركيه شملت القنابل ضوئيه على
مواقع لتلك القوات بريف عين العرب كوباني
الحدوديه مع تركيا من جهتها قالت وسائل
الاعلام مواليه للقوات الكرديه ان القصف
التركيه سادفا نقاطا مشتركه بما تعرفوا
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه وقوات النظام
السوري في قريه جاركلي في عين العرب
كوباني ما اسفر عن اصابه عنصر تابعا لقوات
النظام
هذه تطورات وتزنت مع اجتماعي وزير الدفاع
التركيه خلصي اكار مع قاده الجيش في مدينه
هاكاري على حدود بلاده مع العراق وقد جاء
هذا الاجتماع الذي احتضنه مركز قياده
الفرقه البريه الثالثه في اكاري غداه
اجتماع الليلي عقده اكار معقده الجيش في
مقر قياده القوه البريه بالعاصمه انقره
[موسيقى]
لملخصات هذا الموضوع معنى من انقر الدكتور
مراد
يشيل تاج مدير السياسات الخارجيه في معهد
السته
من بنسلفانيا دكتور اندرويد المدير السابق
لقسم سوريا في مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
والمستشار السابق للمبعوث الامريكي الخاص
الى سوريا
مراد من يقصد الرئيس اردوغان في كلامه ان
لا احد بامكانه وقف هذه العمليه هل يقصدها
الولايات المتحده بشكل مباشر
اوف كورس ده ميني
اكسبرسيه ومنها الولايات المتحده من بين
البرازها هناك ايضا على قات ماتينا بين
الولايات المتحده وتركيا ولكن هناك عدم
اتفاق بالنسبه الى موضوع شمال سوريا
لا سيما مع عمليه تركيا لمكافحه الارهاب
ضد قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه وحدات حمايه
الشعب العربيات المتحده تدعم ووحدات حمايه
الشعب في سوريا مع انها منظمه تعبئه حزب
العمال الكردستاني مع انا الولايات
المتحده ادراجته على قائمه الارهاب طبعا
ان رساله الرئيس التركي
الضوء على ان الولايات المتحده لا يمكنها
ان تتصدى
لعمليه تركيا اذا قررت تركيا ان تتخذ
اجراءات عسكريه شامله ولكن الموضوع ليس
حكرا على الولايات المتحده هناك جهه خديجه
اخرى من عروسيا روسيا ايضا تقف ضد
العمليات عسكريه تركيا لكن اذا نظرنا الى
موقف روسيا لاسيما بعد موق بعد حرب هذا
اوكرانيا فقد تغير موقفها من تركيا هذا لا
يعني بالضروره ان روسيا سوف تدعم العمليه
تركيه مباشره
وانها ستعطي ضوء الاخضر لها لكن روسيا
تفقه ان
حرص تركيا على احتواء تهديدي وحدات حمايه
الشعب لاسيه في غربي المنطقه الخارجيه
خارجيه لاسيما ايران
لطالما وقفت ايران ضد الوجود التركي
العسكريه في سوريا
وبالتالي اذا نظرنا الى سياسه ايران
الاخيره
تجاهها الوجود التركيه العسكري واحتمال
قيام تركيا بعمليه عسكريه طبعا
ايضا الى حكومه
ورجعوا برمانوس
ان النظام الاسد وحكومه الاسد سوف لن يدعى
ما العمل العسكريه التركيه السيد مراد
من كلامك يفهم ان الرساله موجه بالدرجه
الاولى الى الولايات المتحده ومن ثم الى
روسيا وايران والنظام السوري دكتور اندرو
الولايات المتحده كيف يمكن ان تتلقى هذه
الرساله وهل اااه فعلا ليس بامكان
الولايات المتحده ان توقف تركيا عن تنفيذ
هذه العمليه خصوصا اذا ما قرنت او همم اذا
ما همم ارفقت بعمل بريه شمالي سوريا
نايل
الولايات المتحده لا تريد لتركيا ان تدخل
الى سوريا من اجل
هذا الوضع القائم والراهن في سوريا في
الولايات المتحده تريد ان تحمل نظام الاسد
على توصل الى تسويه من خلال المفاوضات
وتبقى هذه سياسه الولايات المتحده وستبقى
كذلك المستقبل ولكن اجابه على سؤالكم لا
يمكن الولايات المتحده ان تفعل اي شيء
عسكري طبعا من اجل منع تركيا من دخول
منطقه مختلفه في شمال سوريا يعتمد الموضوع
على المنطقه التي تتحدث عنها هل نتحدث عن
تعرفها او كوباني او خيرها
السؤال المطروح بالنسبه الى تركيا
باي ثمن بثمانيه علاقتها مع الولايات
المتحده مع دول المجاوره لها وغيرها ولكن
يبدو ان تركيا مصممه وعزيمه على دخول
سوريا لكي تتصدى لقوه ناديمقراطيه وحدات
حمايه الشعب السؤال هنا الى اي مدى هي نفس
الاسئله المطروحه في العامين 2018 و 19
حين كنت لازال الامل مع الحكومه
او القبول الامريكي او غض النظر الامريكي
انما يعتمد على حجم هذه العمليه ومدى
العمق الذي همم تذهب اليه هذه العمليه
العسكريه بمعنى انه ليس هناك رفض للمبدا
بقدر ما هناك رفض للمساحه او ال- ال-
النطاق الجغرافي لهذه العمليه صحيح
عايزين كساوه
انهم يريدون ان يحضوا
الانتشار الجغرافي لهذا العمل بالنسبه الى
اهداف تركيا في سوريا في سنوات الاخيره
تمحورت حول عدم دخول كل منطقه في شمال
سوريا حيث تتواجد سوريا ديمقراطيه وحده
حمايه الشعب او غيرها
من ذلك ان تتصدى لوحدات حمايه الشعب وانت
حد من حجمها بحيث تمنعها من القيام
باعتداء اكبر نطاقا في تركيا او في منطقه
جغرافيه اخرى في بعض المناطق حول تعريف
الحركه فيها تكون اسهل حين ندخل الى
كوباني الى شرق البلاد
تواجهه القوات الامريكيه
فتسبب لها مشاكل كبيره لا بل ستتصرف بذكاء
وتسيطر على مناطق في سوريا يمكنها تحكم
بها وتستخدمها من اجل ان تتصدى لوحده
حمايه الشعب وتحد من حجمها وتغير من
سلوكها هدفا النهائي
هل تركيا في وارد ان ااه تاخذ بعين
الاعتبار التحفظات الامريكيه وان جغرافيه
هنا تحديدا ان تاخذ النقاط او الخطوط
الحمر التي ترسمها الولايات المتحده على
الارض ان تاخذها بعين الاعتبار مقابل همم
دخولها بريا وشن عمليه عسكريه بعنوان
حمايه حدود تركيا
كورسعينات
قد اخذت في الاعتبار الموقف الامريكي في
سوريا لان دولهتين في نهايه المطاف هما
حلفتان لا تريدان
تقف احداهما ضد الاخرى هذا امر منطقي
اعتقد ان تركيا سوف لن تشنا عمل عسكريه
الحدود مع سوريا لا هناك تدخلات ربما في
انكينا استراتيجيه في مواقع تطرح تهديدات
لتركيا سيما في منطقه همم تل رفعت التي
فعلت تطرح تهديدا كبيرا ليس فقط تركيا
ولكن ايضا
اه المنقل امنه في شمال البلاد هناك ايضا
منبت وهي ايضا اخر لحزب العمال الكردستاني
وتطرح ايضا مشاكل مع او بتعاون مع وحدات
حمايه الشعب باستخدام هذا الموقع فيه منبج
هناك ايضا
منطقه كوباني
احد الاهداف العسكريه للتركيا وربما تشن
تركيا عمليات ضد وحدات حمايه الشعب في
كوباني
تطرحوا تهديدا ضد استقرار تركيا لان تركيا
تحاولوا ان تكون هذه المنطقه مستقره
بالنسبه الى شرق نهر يجب ان يكون هناك
توافق بين تركيا والولايات المتحده لشني
هذا العمل العسكريه لان الولايات المتحده
ايضا لديها بعض المواقع العسكريه لا نعرف
ما هو عدد القوات
العسكريه الامريكاني دكتور مراد دكتور
مراد اذا كانت هذه النقاط اذا كانت هذه
النقاط كما تقول همم ربما تغض النظر عنها
الولايات المتحده لكن يبقى السؤال الذي
اطرحه الدكتور اندرو باي ثمن يعني هل تريد
تركيا لهذه العمليه ال ال العسكريه ان
تكون على حساب علاقاتها مع روسيا على حساب
علاقاتها مع ايران همم هل يمكن ان تضحي
بذلك من اجل العمليه العسكريه التي قد
توافق عليها الولايات المتحده بحدود معينه
دكتور مراد يا امين
الوقائع العسكريه والثانيه الوقائع الجو
السياسيه
اتجاه تركيا من وجهه نظرين عسكري
الدنماركيه العسكريه طبعا الولايات
المتحده
مخاوف عسكريه متعدده لا سيما القوات
تنظيم الدوله مره اخرى هذا احد مخاوف
الولايات المتحده الرئيسيه لكن تركيا لا
تريد ان توقف
حرب ضد تنظيم الدوله امام من منظور جيوس
سياسي واذا نظرنا الى المنطقه لا سيما بعد
اجتياح روسيا لاوكرانيا نرى ان ايران
تحاول ان تسد الثغرات في الميدان في ساحه
المعارك تحاول ان تسد هذا الخواء او هذا
الفراغ العسكري والسياسي وهذا ما لا تريد
الولايات المتحده لهذا تنظر الولايات
المتحده في هذه الديناميكيات الجو
السياسيه مع انه يجب ان ناخذ في الاعتبار
التظاهرات الايرانيه في الداخل الايراني
والتي من شانها ان تؤثره على الوجود
الايراني في سوريا بناء عليها انا لا
اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده ستقف ضد
العمليات تركيا اللاسياما في المنطقه
الغربيه من نهر الفرات ولكن بالنسبه الى
منطقه الشرقيه
الولايات المتحده ستكثر مخاوفها اتجاه
العمليه العسكريه التركيه ولكن لم تجبني
فيما يتعلق بروسيا وايران التي همم تعارضا
او قد تعرضان هذه العمليه بشكل او باخر
ساعود اليك في هذا في هذه النقطه لكن
دكتور اندرو الولايات المتحده هنا
هل تتعامل مع العمليه العسكريه كان في
شمال العراق او في شمال سوريا على همم
بنفس المستوى وبنفس الموقف
بعدين
كل ما كان لدينا عمليه عسكريه في دوله
اخرى سوف تتعامل الولايات المتحده مع ذلك
بخوف وحذر شديدين بالنسبه الى نقطه التي
اثارها دكتور مراد سابقا فيما يتعلق
بانتشار القوات العسكريه الامريكيه هذا
احد مخاوف الولايات المتحده في المنطقه
الشرقيه في سوريا القوات الامريكيه موجوده
ايضا في العراق والولايات المتحده قلقه
ايضا من التحركات الايرانيه الاخيره في
الدوله الثانيه
من اجل همم او بالاحرى بنسبه الى تركيا هي
مساعد
للقيام بهذه العمليه همم تحدي من نطاقي
تحركات وحدات حمايه الشعب والولايات
المتحده اذا راى ذلك
سوف ترغب في دخول في مناقشه
ماذا هذا العمل حتى لا
تنسوا هذا الهدوء سائد في سوريا منذ 2018
على امل ان ينقلنا ذلك الى مسار سلام
وعمليه سلام في سوريا راينا انها في بطء
شديد
من حديثك يثار سؤال مهم دكتور اندرو اليست
الولايات المتحده حديثه للقوات الكرديه
هناك لوحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه
واي بي جي
الى وحده حمايه الشعب جزء من قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه كقوه لتصدي لتنظيم الدوله
اعتقد وهذا ليس امرا حديثا طبعا يعود الى
سنوات اعتقد ان مخاوف تركيا
تستمر في الاعتماد على وحدات حمايه الشعب
من اجل التصدي لداعش ولكن تركيا اشارت الى
النقطه مهمه وهي احد من مخاوف المشروعه
فانها علاقه وحدات حمايه الشعب حزب العمال
كردستاني علاقه مستمره وطالما ان ذلك
مستمر لا يمكننا ان نتفاجئ اذا كانت تركيا
سوريا
تركيا ضد حلفاء الولايات المتح ده همم في
في سوريا صحيح
تبدا واين تنتهي اذا كانت العمليه ضدها
تعرف هل هي دوده وحدات حمايه الشعب او
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه ربما اذا كانت في
كوباني او في اي مكان اخر في الشرق سوريا
وحصل التدخل مباشره ضد القوات الامريكيه
نعم سيكون هناك مشكله اعتقد ان هذه
العمليه ستكون في الوسط صحه القول
حين ذلك
ستقرر واشنطن كيف تتعامل مع الموضوع حتى
الان راينا ان تصريحات لم تكن متطرفه
وسنرى كيف ستتبلور الامور في الايام
المقبله
للنقاش امريكيا لكن يبقى الموقف الروسي
والموقف الايراني وايضا موقف العراق لا
يمكن الوصول الى نتائج عبر التفاوض مثلا
لو اخذنا شمال اا العراق هل يمكن ان تقبل
تركيا
بقوات
فدراليه قوات اتحاديه همم من بغداد
بالاشتراك مع البيشمركه للانتشار على
الحدود لمنع عمليه عسكريه او تغلغل تركي
في شمال العراق
ايتين اي وقت
تماما اذا قرنه بالملف السوري بما ان
عمليات مكافحه الارهاب التركيه مستمره منذ
2016 وطبعا غيرت تركيا سياسه مكافحه
الارهاب الخاصه بها اذا هناك الكثير من
الديناميكيات المتداخله على الارض في
العراق طبعا حكومه بغداد هي جزء لا يتجزء
من هذه الديناميكيه لكن في نهايه المطاف
فان عددا من
القوات الكرديه موجوده هناك همم اذا
النظام سياسي بين هذه الاطراف الكرديه في
شمال العراق
تدعم العمليه التركيه العسكريه في شمال
العراق من اجل
الوشود السياسيه والعسكري الخاصه
وجود البي كاكا ايضا هو ينسف الاستقرار في
همم شمع العراق اذا نعم هناك همم اوجه
اختلاف بين بغداد وانقره بالنسبه الى
العمليه التركيه العسكريه المستمره ولكن
هذا يعتمدوا على اتفاقات الدفاع المشترك
بين الحكومه المركزيتين في بغداد وانقره
الحكومه في بغداد ايضا سعيده بشان العمل
العسكريه مع انها قالت انها تركيا
تقود السياده العراقيه وسلامه اراضي
العراق ولكن في النهايه هي حرب ضد
البيكاكولا اذا كان العراق سوف يستفيد من
هذا النظافه هذا امر مفيد
وشمال العراق او الحكومه كردستان العراق
من شانها ايضا ان تستفيد من هذه العمل يا
العسكريه التركيه في العراق هذا الامر
يختلف عن الموضوع السوري
مراد يا شيل طاش مديره سياسه الخارجيه في
معهد سيتم من انقره شكرا لكم شكرا للدكتور
اندرو تابلورم من سلفانيا المستشار السابق
للمبعوث الامريكيه الخاص الى سوريا
[موسيقى]